a lot of people consider mini golf to be
very benign and all fun in games but at
this level it can be a cut throat
competition
among the greatest players in the world
[Music]
my name is matt male i'm a professional
mini golfer
[Music]
i was a regular golfer ever since
childhood i started at about eight years
old
and putting was always the greatest
facet of my game the idea of doing
nothing but putting for 18 holes
instantly appealed to me and i just
began practicing a lot
people don't realize that mini golf is a
highly precise sport
improvement can come
very tediously
to be competitive it really requires
an extensive
mapping of each hole
and we can be out here for up to 10
hours a day or so for several days
before a tournament
when i first arrive at a course
i diagnose the holes
i want to come up with a clear plan of
attack on each hole and then just it's a
matter of repetition from there
[Music]
we are at the 2016 mini golf masters in
north myrtle beach south carolina this
tournament is the premier event each
year in mini golf
it draws players from all over the world
the green jacket is the most coveted
prize in mini golf
the competition is very fierce the
players here are the best of the best
and it's an immense challenge because
even a stretch of five bad minutes or
ten bad minutes can disqualify you from
contention
just a tiny miscue here or there can
spell major disaster on one hole
[Music]
i really do have an authentic admiration
of what the winner had to do to to
perform
under the pressure of of such a major
tournament because
i i know from experience how hard it is
mini golf's not a sport for everyone
there's constant frustration there's
constant adversity
it
it rewards patience and it rewards
determination
and it never gets old to see the ball go
in the hole
i don't think that thrill will ever go
away
[Music]
when i tell people i'm a pro football
player there's always a
look of like astonishment
i get laughter sometimes too but i don't
know there's tournaments for that
foosball yeah that's the one that's
that's what i do
[Music]
foosball is not just a bar room game
it's a competitive sport that's played
at a professional level by people all
around the world
it's like a hand-to-hand combat you're
standing this close you know you're
standing three feet away from your
opponent and it's almost like you're in
a fight you're battling against each
other
i come from a long line of foosball
players
i got into foosball because of my dad
he played in the the golden era the
1970s when there was a million-dollar
tour i've been playing for 20 years now
so for the first 10 to 12 years of my
career i would practice on a table at
home it would be complete repetition
over and over and over
every player in here can execute a shot
or a pass but it's a matter of
constructing a solid game plan it's like
a a game of chess on the mental side
it's it could be pretty taxing
physically by the end of the weekend
you're sore your hands are sore your
feet are sore so you have to be in
decent shape i always get a sweat band
on my arm just in case i get into a
heated match i get a
you know wipe my brow so
i go to
the world cup which is basically our
version of the olympics and i compete on
team usa
i do believe it should be in the
olympics
our only problem is the fact that
there's not a standardized foosball
table
and i'll do whatever it takes to uh for
the sport to reach that next level
bottom line is it makes me happy that
this is what i do and
yeah i love it
[Music]
oftentimes you hear people say that
they've done double dutch but most
people have never experienced what
double dutch is now it's a competitive
sport you're jumping so that you'll be
able to win
my name is kenya robinson and i'm a part
of floyd's little double dust team which
is located in north new jersey i'm 17
years old and i've been jumping double
dutch for five years
i practice with the double dust team
three times a week we compete four times
a year and it leads up to the world
competition and my team has 19 world
championship titles we're currently in
competition season and everyone is
aiming to win the trophy
joining the double dutch it gave me a
safe place it gave me a home this isn't
just jumping rope
i was born and raised in newark new
jersey and newark is a city where a lot
of violence occurs it's not always safe
to be outside a lot of shooting
happening i just never know what to
expect
growing up i didn't have the mother
relationship with my with my own mother
so i feel like coming to double dutch
has really
opened my eyes and let me know that
there is people who care about me i have
a support system whenever i need it
double dutch is where i need to be
[Music]
it takes a person with endurance to take
the person with strength it takes a
person with the positive attitude in
order to be a winner in order to be that
person who knows how to jump
in double dutch competition the most
important component of double dutch is
speed that's how fast the jumper in the
rope can jump
giving the support to the jumper is a
job that's really important to me
because growing up i didn't have that
support and i know that i want to give
the support that i never had to the
person who's in the rope to so they can
know that no matter how many mistakes
you did you can come back from it you're
still going to be a winner at the end of
the day
they have what it takes to win the
tournament
[Music]
day-to-day living i find it can be
pretty mundane and you know when i'm out
there you've just got a really simple
task which is to survive and enjoy life
my name is gavin mcclure and i'm a
cross-country paraglider
we're basically flying a modified bed
sheet and strings we don't have a motor
and we're just using thermals thermals
are kind of like the gas for a car we
get as high as we possibly can and then
we glide and if we find another thermal
we can keep going
i've flown in the himalayas i've flown
in morocco i've flown all over the alps
in europe and the canadian rockies and
we're just looking at a map in a
completely different way these days
hurricane ridge is one of the most
spectacular places
for me in the world is this beautiful
long ridge that ties right in with the
grand canyon it sits right on the edge
of zion national park
[Music]
i was doing this expedition with some of
the best pilots in the world and
right as the sun set you know the
conditions just went bang on and
we all launched into the sky and you
know paragliding can be really intense
and sometimes really scary and very
dangerous and this was like the opposite
of that it was just playful and fun and
we were doing huge wing overs and acro
and
when i'm flying over these really remote
places
i think what it gives you is a
perspective and an awe that is
impossible to get in any other way
these guys and i are people that you
know we really chase records and we
chase huge distances and made us realize
that you know it's it's not about the
records and it's not about flying huge
distances it's just about enjoying the
freedom of flight
[Music]
you